but first over the past few nights we've
been laying out the coordinated effort
by a cabal of diplomatic and Intel
bureaucrats to upend the presidency of
Donald Trump now when the president
called them out for their catastrophic
failures of process and policy they were
offended when he demanded that NATO
countries stopped free riding on the US
tax pirate pairs they were horrified and
when he began making good on his promise
to bring home our troops they were
shocked and when the deep States
insurance policy and Russia collusion
narrative imploded they decided to bring
in reinforcements and of course they
found them in the house where Democrats
are furiously trying to construct an
abuse of power article of impeachment I
have a question if Trump is so obviously
off the rails why not hold their fake
impeachment inquiry out in the open
sunlight is after all the best political
disinfectant well easy answer the closed
door shuffle allows Democrats to preset
the theme of each witness spin the
secret testimony cherry-pick then leak
the phrases most favorable to their
impeachment narrative acting ambassador
to Ukraine bill Taylor a never Trumper
himself had his turn in the Star Chamber
today it's not even noon right and this
is the my most disturbing day in
Congress so far very troubling the
testimony was explosive I will say that
this is the top witness that we purged
for him so far and he gave a tremendous
testimony today but sources familiar
with the testimony tell Fox News that
Taylor didn't offer any new evidence and
had zero first-hand knowledge or direct
evidence of the quid pro quo that
Democrats claimed was a slam dunk but
this isn't about this isn't about the
truth this is about just confirming a
thesis regardless of the fact that for
instance the UK and Krane president said
there was no pressure applied to him and
no quid pro quo
which brings us to the media they've
been aching for impeachment since
election night and thus will pair it
whatever Adam Schiff spits out no
questions asked it is entirely possible
that this day may turn out to be one of
the most consequential days in the
impeachment inquiry Donald Trump's
impeachment may have been turbocharged
today by the testimony of career
diplomat Bill Taylor bill Taylor was not
just a smoking gun this was a smoking
howitzer that's from Max Headroom and it
gets better
they don't just publish articles with
completely anonymous sources last year
remember the New York Times published an
entire op IDI
written by an anonymous supposedly a
senior trump official who even claimed
to be himself part of the resistance
patriotic resistance well of course mr.
or miss courageous also shopped a book
deal it drops next month according to
the publisher the author sees this as an
act of conscience and of duty
what a crock every anti Trump eart Adler
is depicted as a selfless saint in the
media this so it all smacks of
desperation to me but less hatred for
this president has been well documented
but what they are now openly signaling
is that they don't like you the American
voter either they don't trust you to
deliver a result that they want so they
will try to remove this entire process
from your hands altogether the president
won election nearly three years ago as
an outsider and I was thinking about
this and I think today ironically he's
still kind of an outsider what do I mean
I mean that the bipartisan establishment
they never accepted him as legitimate
now this despite his stellar economic
record record number of judges confirmed
and the leadership he's shown against
the China threat he's still a disruptor
he's still the ultimate Rorschach test
for the old guard the veteran merica
does under Trump the more negatively
they think that reflects on the
so-called experts
who for decades squandered American
prosperity for a globalist fantasy so if
they can impeach Trump even on a bogus
narrative teased out in secret
the permanent resistance can say see I
told you so and feel vindicated this is
their revenge yet as usual they
underestimate the common sense of the
American people who may just have their
own revenge against the globalist
impeachment mob on November 2nd 2020